the Ethiopian government has agreed a
peace deal with to grain Rebels after
two years of fighting the cessation of
hostilities was announced in Pretoria
where the two warring signs have been
holding negotiations there was a surge
in fighting before the Diplomatic
breakthrough mediated by the African
Union at least half a million people
have died from fighting hunger and
disease related to the conflict in the
region
today
is the beginning of a new town for
Ethiopia
for the end of Africa
and indeed for Africa as a whole
let me explain to some God
for this Newton
we have seen in practice and
actualization
what we have tried to achieve for
ourselves over the years
and that is
African solution
for African problems
let's bring in famita Miller who joins
us live from Pretoria and has been
covering these developments for me to
what more can you tell us about this
agreement
well I think the key points of the
agreement have come in the opening
remarks from one of the mediators the
former Nigerian president obasanjo
olusegun who has said that number one
there will be a silencing of the guns uh
which ultimately would provide a solid
foundation for the preservation of
Ethiopia sovereignty as well as
territorial Integrity that of course
meaning the immediate cessation of
hostilities and also key uh given just
the some of the devastation and
difficulties experienced during this
hostility the two years of conflict is
an immediate resumption of unhindered
humanitarian access we know that
thousands of people have been killed
people have also been affected by the
lack of supply of food and numeric
militarian Aid in the tigray region and
this is really has been a vital sticking
point in terms of some of the
difficulties that have occurred in the
last two years we know that the great
Representatives have in these talks and
into the media have also said that that
Grant people have not only been affected
by bullets that hasn't just killed
people but also the issue of hunger so I
think key in terms of these negotiators
negotiated settlement is uh the
cessation of hostilities the resumption
of Aid people returning to their places
of work children returning to school and
both parties have said they would want
the immediate implementation and really
what is key now is just how well this
agreement is implemented
indeed familiar and how difficult has it
been to reach an agreement and where to
from here
well I think one comment from the South
African minister of international
relations and uh international relations
is uh lady Pando who had said in her
remarks that she is one of the most
relieved people in the room given how
sensitive these talks have been and she
in fact was reluctant for South Africa
to host these peace talks just because
of the Dynamics involved the different
parties involved in perhaps the
background in terms of the ethnic
difficulties uh with regard to the
tigraine people and the federal
government of Ethiopia and that this has
been very difficult it has been 10 days
of negotiations and there hasn't always
been official feedback around exactly
what's happening but some of what's come
out of these talks is that it has been
difficult getting to this point and
there were a number of sticking points
especially given that the grand people
have had a very influential uh role to
play in the politics of Ethiopia prior
to 2018 they were the most influential
and that was before the Prime Minister
ABI Ahmed Ahmed came to power and that
also changed that Dynamic despite a
constitution allowing to Grant people
potentially having a Channel 4 secession
ultimately and this is also what
contributed to some of the hostilities
and people taking up arms now again what
is important is the implementation of
this agreement given that there was
cessation uh earlier this year but that
fell apart by August and so what happens
next I think will be watched very keenly
also given some of the international of
what people are calling Ethiopian people
are calling International interference
in the hostilities and conflict in that
country so those rumored to be involved
those officially involved would also
need to ultimately be party to this
agreement it wouldn't necessarily only
be up to Ethiopian people but also
foreign actors that have involved
themselves
familiar the agreement is only a few
hours old if less than an hour old
officially how much confidence is there
that it will actually hold
well one of the interesting points from
the to Grand Representatives is that
they've said they've had to make painful
concessions uh but this is in the
interest of uh building trust between
themselves and the federal government of
Ethiopia and it's quite interesting that
they've used that word in painful
concessions because I think we can
conclude that this hasn't been the
easiest agreement to come to and perhaps
the grand people are not entirely happy
with all of uh the agreements put in
place ultimately yes a cessation of
hostilities but we have also heard from
some on the tagorean side who have said
that they want the the conflict is one
where there have been humanitarian
abuses we've also heard that kind of
allegation from both sides of both
warring sides against the other but
there has been a difficulty integrating
people wanting a greater voice in the
federal government in Ethiopia and also
ultimately potentially some level of
autonomy so it's not certain if the
agreement does come date all of their
needs but they haven't expressed entire
happiness but certainly putting them
humanitarian situation ahead of perhaps
the political Ambitions yes speaking of
that humanitarian situation it's
certainly been well documented half a
million people have died from various
situations in terms of starvation or
within the conflict itself is there hope
that the agreement will alleviate some
of that pressure
well that is one of the key points which
in the agreement that there will be an
immediate access to humanitarian Aid
we've heard during this conflict from
the two warring sides one saying the
Ethiopian federal government saying the
areas that they've taken over in the
tegre region there has been humanitarian
access where it's whereas the grand
people have said well that isn't the
case at all uh people outside of the
country are unable to communicate
communicate with family members with
Integra throughout this two-year period
and that's the claim that they're making
so we are hearing different pieces of
information from those from those two
sides and also knowing that accessing
that part of the country by the media
hasn't necessarily been very easy but
what is important at this stage is the
return to at least to some extent
normality in that part of the country
access to hospitals access to food we
also know that the internet as well as
mobile phone services have been out
there's been talk of electricity not
being available and so really what is
key at this point is that assistance to
the people of that region both sides
have agreed to that that the the
difficulties experience the severity of
the conflict has impacted people very
badly and what is key at this point is
to help people in that region indeed
thank you so much for bringing us up to
spade for me to Miller live for us in
Pretoria South Africa thank you